Я збираю підписи за Ксенію Собчак. Може, поставите?
На дідька вона здалася!
Перехожий має на увазі її
Це Ксенія Собчак: напориста, різка, безцеремонна
Колись найвідоміша світська леді Росії,
потім незалежна журналістка
До Собчак добре ставляться молоді люди
які хоч і проти Путіна, але на барикади
через це йти не хочуть
На відміну від нього
Олексій Навальний – найбільш затятий
критик Кремля
хоча й не може балотуватися через судимість
закликає своїх молодих прибічників
знову й знову до протестів та бойкоту виборів
На противагу йому - чинний президент Володимир Путін
Для російського президента головне - явка
Чим вища активність виборців, тим легітимнішим буде здаватися його переобрання
в якому ніхто не сумнівається
Не лише його прихильники
Мені подобається бути громадянином Росії
під керівництвом такого
сильного лідера як Володимир Путін
Я постійно чекаю, що за мною приїде ФСБ
за те, що я запостила не ту картинку чи статтю
Ксенія Собчак і сама каже, що вона йде
не для того, щоб президенткою стати
Вона ж обрала чітко стратегію проти всіх
Звичайно, не йде на амбразуру, як Навальний
Саме тому її пускають на телебачення
Саме тому Путін значною мірою
використовує її як інструмент
щоб показати: ось же в нас свобода слова
Я упевнена в тому, що всі, окрім Навального,
це проекти Кремля.
Так звані ширмочки і спойлери
покликані легітимізувати перепризначення Путіна
Навальний – єдиний, хто може вивести
людей на вулиці, в мороз, кілька тисяч
Насправді нам видається, що в Радянському Союзі
комсомол справді був доброю
школою для молодих громадян
Це й досі актуально: і злети, і заходи,
які ми проводимо
Можна виходити на вулицю не лише для мітингу
Можна ж іще проводити суботники
Це вияв нашої громадянської позиції
влада повинна знати, ЩО ми думаємо
А сидіти вдома на дивані – доля комах
Безумовно, серед молоді більше опозиціонерів
Але серед молоді також є люди,
котрі якраз навпаки
раді жити за Путіна,
тому що все життя вони живуть сито
Зараз все-таки відчутно, що і наша культура стала популярнішою за кордоном
і позиція  нашої країни стала більш упевненою
За Путіна ніхто не вийде на багатотисячний мітинг
Тим більше на неузгоджений
Тим більше в холод і з ризиком бути заарештованим
Вони – не за Путіна. Вони байдужі
І наше завдання – перетягувати цих байдужих на свій бік
Необхідно висловлювати
свою думку і свою позицію
в межах законодавства нашої країни
Або ж працювати більш конструктивно
Якщо законодавство не подобається,
обиратись депутатами і законодавство міняти
Путін через три роки десь піде у відставку
Тому що в нього вже явно не витримують нерви.
Він вже "здає"
І чим більше ми будемо розгойдувати човен, показувати народне невдоволення
Чому ми всі виходимо?
Щоб розгойдувати дійсно човен
Хоч нам це ставлять у провину, це треба робити
Щоб він не відсидів ще один термін,
а пішов раніше, мирно
У Росії опозиційною політикою
займатись дуже важко
На кожному кроці - перешкоди
Якби я мешкав у якомусь Кемерові,
не кажучи вже про Чечню
то, можливо, я був би не таким активним
Чого боятися? Ну, знаєте, два виходи:
померти стоячи або жити на колінах
Я обираю перше
Якщо колись тут будуть барикади,
я буду на них у перших лавах
Ми підтримуємо президента
Ми підтримуємо його рішення
висуватися на вибори
І члени нашої організації, я впевнений, підуть на вибори і підтримають нашого президента
Прихильники Навального, фани Собчак чи віддана молодь Путіна
вже давно російська молодь не була такою політично активною
як на цих президентських виборах